Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie! This
is going to be my new video for the Batman
movie with Matt Reeves and Robert
Pattinson Warner Brothers just made a
couple big announcements the actors were
also talking about their characters the
story in the long Halloween so we'll
break it all down I was doing a movie
ticket giveaway but because of the
craziness we'll just make that an Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave all your
theories about the Batman movie on the
video so we'll just break this down top
5 style starting with number 5 the
Batman movie has officially been put on
hiatus for a couple weeks because of all
the craziness they're still in the
middle of the filming they have a long
ways to go most people are just
quarantine ting themselves for the next
two weeks so the Batman will start
filming again in about two weeks the
good news is that it won't affect the
release date of the movie the Batman
movie is currently coming out June 2021
next summer
number four there are four villains in
the movie with a lot more in the
background who will move up the bench in
the sequels the main ones are obviously
the Oswald Cobblepot penguin played by
Colin Farrell the Edward gnashed in
version of the Riddler played by Paul
Dano Edward nation' is just more true to
the comic book Riddler's name the movie
is pulling from a lot of comic book deep
cuts and classic Batman stuff as I'll
explain as we go along here
then there's the Selina Kyle Catwoman as
we all know played by zoe kravitz
although technically i don't really
consider a Catwoman as much of a Batman
villain as it's sometimes a lie and love
interest who also just happens to work
with a lot of the criminals she creates
a lot of interesting problems for the
Batman but in a much more playful way so
she just walks the line between evil and
good a lot better than some of the other
villains is the way they're portraying
them in the movie based on what the
actors are saying about their characters
and the teasers so far not all the major
Batman villains will be portrayed as
straight-up villains in the movie even
the ones that you would think of is the
most classic of Batman villains but the
fourth kind of big villain of sorts is
the current district attorney Gill :
played by Peter Sarsgaard he's not a
comic book character in they're not
lying about him being original to the
movie it's not a situation where he's
secretly playing two-face and they gave
him a fake name to talk about in the
press it'll make more sense when you
hear him talk about the character he's
someone that Matt Reeves created it just
for this first Batman
he describes his character is a very
very bad person in this clip.
You're in the upcoming Batman.
I am. The Batman.
With Robert Patttinson
Now this is a new
character as a new character created
for the movie right called Gil...
Yeah yeah. Gil Colson.
And I'm a district attorney and...
I'm basically a...
a politician that has trouble telling the truth.
What a novel idea.
Now of course for the people out there
who may not remember your lovely wife
Maggie Gyllenhaal was also in the The
Dark Knight she was okay now do your
children your children have to choose
which a non Batman character from a
Batman movie they love more are they
prepared are you going to put the screws to
the kids
I mean hers is so lovely.
Her character I mean.
I'm a really distasteful person in it.
Daddy doesn't play nice people.
You know, typically. Typically let's be honest the
guy in this is not very nice.
The funny thing about that a lot of you may not
have known that he was actually married
to Maggie Gyllenhaal who played Rachel
Dawes in Batman The Dark Knight during
the Christian Bale era so both of their
characters both worked for the office of
the district attorney in different
Batman movies just a coincidence I
didn't include it in the clip there but
during that same interview he talked
about how he raises bats in real life
with his family at his house and tried
to explain to Matt Reeves on the set of
the Batman movie when they were getting
ready for a particular scene about how
the way the Batman character is
typically portrayed in all these movies
TV shows comic books doesn't really
reflect the real-life behavior of bats
and proceeded to explain all the
ridiculous things that bats do in real
life like screeching really high and
loud flying around really erratically
packin together really tightly and he
said when he suggested to Matt Reeves
and Robert Pattinson before this really
big scene that they were getting ready
to film that they have Robert Pattinson
try doing his Batman that way
they both looked at him like he was the
craziest person that they'd ever met but
number three one of the biggest new
villains who's not really a villain in
the first new Batman movie is two-face
obviously Harvey Dent he had been
rumored for a while
early on when Matt Reeves was still
writing the movie and figuring out who
was going to be his Batman
then people who read the early drafts of
the Batman script kept talking about how
it was inspired by Batman the long
Halloween mixed with a lot of other
classic Batman stories and designs
recently Jeffrey Wright who's playing
detective Gordon tweeted a picture of
himself doing research by reading
Batman's along Halloween confirming
those rumors and during that story
Harvey Dent's transformation into
two-face is one of the biggest most
central character turns of the story
because of the way he's connected to the
other major characters in the story the
long Halloween is kind of an origin
story for two-face in a sense but since
Matt Reeves has replaced Harvey Dent in
this first Batman movie with the Gil
Colson character early theory is that
they made Gil Coulson a terrible
politician district attorney that Batman
and the other villains like the Riddler
want to take down that way once they get
rid of him or kill him off maybe Harvey
Dent takes his place at either the end
of the first movie or the beginning of
the Batman sequel and that will put them
on the path to doing a new version of
two-face I thought that Aaron Eckhart's
to face was pretty decent in the Dark
Knight but he did a fantastic Harvey
Dent and he was really only the two-face
persona for the last little bit of the
movie so we didn't really get that
full-blown comic book two-face.
Okay fine.
You either die a hero.
Or you live long
enough to see yourself become the villain.
It sounds like Matt Reeves is planning
on doing a much bigger version of
two-face during his Batman movies and
speaking of new Easter eggs people are
finding more Easter eggs in the new
Batman Batmobile teasers that they
dropped a couple weeks ago so when you
look at the rear headlight configuration
in the body here it actually makes the
shape of a bat in the production
designer on the movie that designed this
new Batmobile and builted said that that
was on purpose so I'm sure there's a lot
of this going on during the movie it'll
be fun to try and spot it we're talking
about the Riddler now number two
speaking of that evil District Attorney
Gil Coulson now we have some more
context for the Batman scene of the
Riddler that leaked a couple weeks ago
there was a scene from the Batman movie
that someone posted from the set
revealing one of the Riddler's victims
I'm sure that person has either since
been fired or put in a deep dark hole
never to return I can't put any of the
footage in here just because the video
would get superb and but it was a man
tied up in a chair
with a sack over his head and one of the
Riddler's messages hung around his neck
it's a little bit like the viral teaser
for the Dark Knight that they released
with the Joker early on where he had
taken one of his victims and was forcing
them to do something on camera the
Riddler's victim in this new Batman
movie had a message written in blood
hanging around his neck and it read no
more lies with a big red question mark
underneath it so based on what Peter
Sarsgaard revealed about his character
having a problem with lying a lot we can
probably say the no more lies line the
Riddler is pissed off about is
referencing District Attorney Gil
Coulson's lies it could also have
something to do with detective Gordon's
arc in the movie - Gordon is still only
a detective when the first movie picks
up at the beginning of the story what'll
probably happen with his characters that
just like during the Dark Knight trilogy
he will slowly replace the current
police commissioner in the sequel or the
last film in the trilogy they did the
exact same thing during Christian Bale's
Batman era so all this just makes the
Riddler seem like less of a straight-up
villain and more of an insane antihero
in his own mind who just steers more
into outright villainy by the end of the
movie
speaking of which we haven't really
heard much about the Penguins role in
this movie version of the long Halloween
but I would expect the same type of
portrayal where : Farrell's penguin
isn't a mustache twirling villain or
even a more obvious villain like Heath
Ledger's Joker from The Dark Knight like
you start at the beginning of The Dark
Knight and you know that the Joker is a
villain nothing he's doing seems like
it's good even though in his own mind
he's somehow justified it an agent of
chaos if the penguin had an alignment it
would be more like lawful evil he has a
very clear sense of order he comes from
old money in Gotham so use that to
picture him as a more organized version
of what you would think of some of the
bigger mobsters in town he is a more
ordered plan for the city that just
happens to be in opposition to Batman's
plans for the city in number 1 obviously
addressing the stuff going on in the
other parts of the DC Universe a lot of
the other DC projects movies and TV
shows have been put on hold for the next
two weeks most of that includes the
flash and all the DC TV shows they're
almost done filming their seasons but
they still have a little ways to go the
good news though is that Wonder Woman
1984 has not been delayed the middle
a lot of movies that were coming out
recently that had been cancelled and
moved to different times later this year
I might do a separate video just for all
that stuff but because Wonder Woman 1984
isn't coming out till June later this
summer that's way outside the current
quarantine danger zone that's happening
right now all over the world what is
happening though right now even for the
movies that are still coming out on time
later this summer is that everyone's
kind of hit pause on the marketing which
is why we haven't seen another Wonder
Woman 1984 trailer recently and why we
haven't seen that first venom 2 trailer
because that all should be happening
right around now everyone in Hollywood
just kind of hit the pause button for
the next few weeks so what will happen
is is I'll just do video updates for big
announcements and things that are going
on in between Easter eggs and deleted
scenes in the normal videos that I would
be posting most TV is still airing just
fine like Westworld season 3 episode 1
is starting this Sunday I'll be doing
weekly videos for Westworld so as long
as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you'll see all those videos
congratulations cosmic Spidey you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details everyone click here for that new
big Marvel spider-man 3 announcement and
click here for the brand-new Batman
teaser trailer video thank you so much
for watching everyone stays safe out
there I'll see you guys tonight!